Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to go ahead and grab that sprite sheet, create
a material for it, and then create a Niagara system and load that material in that system.
So let's get started.
So in here we're going to go ahead and bring in our texture sprite sheet.
Now you can simply just hit the T key and if it's selected you'll notice it will automatically
populate.
But for some reason you don't have it in place, you can simply go in here in our content
drawer, have the sprite sheet selected, grab it, and you should be familiar with this,
but if you're not simply click on the arrow and load it this way.
So what we want to do now is build out this material.
So to build out this material we're going to hit the D key and left click to create the
divide node.
I'm going to pull that RGB string and pull it into the A slot here, and I'm going to
grab the A for the alpha here and pull it into the B slot here.
And then what I can do from here is pull that right into the base color.
Now you'll notice we're actually not quite doing exactly what we want, right?
So to help things out, and there's no alpha information being read, we can simply click
on our original node that we have here, the home base where everything gets plugged in,
and we can go in here underneath our blend mode and set that to translucent.
Now we're not done yet because we now need to grab that alpha and pull it into the opacity.
And you'll see we're going to kind of get a one to one to our original effect.
That's actually pretty cool.
But say you want to have a little bit of glow.
You'll notice in my original sample it has connected right from our divide into the emissive
for a little bit of glow, but it does make things a bit lighter.
So if we look into our scene itself, you'll actually see the effect here brighter than
the one in the distance.
So to be able to control some of that, what you can simply do is go in here and I can
hit the M key and the M key will give us our multiplying.
And then if I want to hit my finger on the S key left click, and we'll have our scalar
and we'll call this emiss one M emissive amounts and plug that into the B channel.
Plug this guy, the divide into the A channel and then grab that and put it into the emissive.
So now if I wanted to increase this, I can create an instance of this material and have
this exposed so that I can control it.
Pretty awesome.
But remember, you have to keep in mind what your sprite sheets number of rows are.
And you'll see we have one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
And we have an eight by eight square.
That's going to be 64.
And that number is going to be key as we build out our emitter.
Let's go ahead and do that real quick here.
So again, we want to make sure when we build our emitter initially, let's go back to the
FX folder, a little bit less busy.
You can see in the in class effects one, because I didn't change the folder, I kept
it here, all of the individual sprites are rendered out as well as a sprite sheet.
So that can be convenient if you need to take these into Photoshop and edit them later for
whatever reason or make a brand new sprite sheet using a software to be able to do so.
But we have an already made, so we're okay there.
So I want to go ahead and right click in here and I go to effects.
And again, I go to Niagara system in this Niagara system, I can hit next, and I can
simply go to an empty slot.
So you can do emitter or system, but just whatever you choose, make sure it's an empty
one, and you just hit a plus and then you hit finish and you're in.
Now we have one here that's already set up here, but let me show you again pointing out
what we have in place.
I made sure that underneath my emitter state, I hit plus and added or I should say update,
I hit plus and I added my spawn burst instantaneous.
And I kept this spawn count to one and the spawn time to zero.
I left those default and that worked just great.
From there, I also want to underneath my particle update, click down the plus arrow, and I added
a sub UV animation.
Click on this one.
And we want to make sure that we're using our start frame of zero like I mentioned before,
and end frame is 63 because we want one just behind the next frame.
Very important to consider.
And then from there, we go to sprite render and under sprite render underneath sub image
size, we change that to eight by eight, like we talked about before.
And finally underneath our initial particle, we want to make sure that our underneath our
sprite attributes, we set the sprite size mode to uniform and then the uniform sprite
size to 500.
This is key so that we actually have the accurate size that we need and it almost does like
a one to one.
Now again, you can change the size to whatever you need for your sprite.
So once you're done, you want to go ahead and hit save and then you simply just drag
it into your scene.
This particular one is going straight from the opacity and the emissive.
The opacity is working great, but the emissive is a little bit bright.
So if we decided to revisit this effect, we can go in here and go to its material.
And if we want to hit save, let's see if we'll update this guy is the one that we kind of
were tweaking with.
And then now we can see that it is a bit darker and a little bit closer to what our original
is.
Now again, keep in mind you're looping.
So if you do want to use this and this isn't too bad, the resolution isn't too shabby,
especially if it's far away.
You want to go ahead and edit things accordingly.
So you can also go in here and edit the glow and Photoshop if you want to.
And there's multiple ways to get this where you want, but this gives you a lower level
effect that you can put in the background.
Again, you do need to consider how many frames you want, how long it's going to play and
how long the camera is going to be looking at it.
Now in another way, which I mentioned earlier, and I'll give you a link at the end of this
course, you can also create a plate that you render out to using Houdini or Emberjan or
Maya and it can be an EXR HDR output and UNRUL will accept that in your scene.
Now this isn't part of this course, that course, but I do offer that link to you if you decide
to go that route and you need something even higher resolution wise.
But this gives you a quick, simple solution versus that EXR one, which gives you even
a higher resolution.
So you have the best of both worlds to play with things.
Again, all of these steps are laid out for you, such as building the material, making
sure that it's translucent, and then making sure you're loading the right texture in your
texture sample node, and then connecting a divide to your opacity emissive.
And also you can connect it to your base color.
But keep in mind, if you connected to your emissive, there could be some brightness there
and kind of just use it the way that I created.
We had a scalar and a multiply and we can downplay that if we need to or increase it
as needed.
And then also in the effect itself, some quick review here again, start frame needs to be
set to zero and end frame in the sub UV animation node that you need to make.
Make sure you also create a spawn burst instantaneous, keep things at default, and then a sprite
renderer you want to make sure the sub UV size is eight and eight underneath your sub
UV category.
And then finally in that Niagara emitter, or I should say system, you should go in here
underneath your sprite attributes.
And in here you want to control and make sure your uniform sprite size is 500.
By default, the life cycle mode should be system on both scalability and life cycle.
But you can triple check this, especially if you're inheriting an effect that someone else
has created, make sure that the life cycle mode for this particular node is set to system
and it sets a system for both of them.
That's it with this lecture.
Here's some links to help you along your journey to give you more information about what we
talked about.
Thanks again.
And in the next video, we'll do a quick recap about everything that we've learned.